I'm gonna talk about three things today
I'm gonna talk about unity which is a
game engine I'm gonna talk about
tensorflow which is a machine learning
framework that comes out of Google I'm
gonna talk about something to glue them
together which is the unity machine
learning agents toolkit which I may
occasionally refer to as unity ml agents
unity ml or various other things all
these words are wrong it is called the
unity machine like if they get very
angry when you call it something
different
unity again game engine this is a quick
introduction to the power of using a
game engine or a simulation engine for
machine learning I think this is really
cool and more people should be doing it
so hopefully you'll get enthused by this
we havein got time to go to in depth
first thing I'm gonna do is look at
unity I'm gonna quickly tear out of my
slides because I think it's best to do
this live because I lost half my slides
anyway so please excuse me while I tell
my my slides in a second but basically
unity is a game engine unity is 60 to 80
percent of the video games industry
depending on how you count which is
terrifying no one company should have
that much power but there you have it we
have that problem that's our one problem
to deal with but unity is mostly free
and it's really useful to play with the
terms that a game engine can simulate
enough of the real world to be useful
for people who need to simulate the real
world to pretend something's in the real
world which is actually quite a fun
thing to do
so alongside game engines being a big
thing in unity being a ridiculously
terrifying percentage of the games
industry machine learning has really
taken off lately in three very specific
different domains those three domains a
cognitive physical and visual so we've
got alpha go doing cognitive things
solving cognitive problems we've got
deep mind and like the open and eye gems
and stuff like that making things walk
with like weird throwing motions and
stuff so physical problems and we've got
visual problems like visitor room where
they talk about to play doom just by
giving it the visual input of doom ok
doom is the old video game so cognitive
physical visual as it turns out a video
game engine can seem like cognitive
physical and visual things very easily
and very quickly
it's a really good place to do that
stuff so that's what unity comes in this
is the MLA just toolkit it's on github
we'll come back to that that's FAR's
just there in case I didn't have an
internet connection I'm gonna turn out
now and show you this live just because
it's easier you can do you write a paper
on it if you want to read more about
this from an academic sense this paper
is really good you do see a general
platform for intelligent agents it's on
archive because every machine learning
paper is on archive it's very it's very
readable
check it out so now it's almost like
time time so I'm gonna push this guy and
go into unity there's going to pick the
right unity because I have three of them
open to show you three different things
that's this one okay so ignore those
errors this is unity in unity you may
think it looks like most other 3d
software this is nothing to do with
machine learning this is just a scene to
acclimatize you with how unity works so
in this scene I've put a ball into the
scene it's called sphere I'm gonna
rename it to ball you'll see it over
here I've got a cube in the skirt scene
which I've flattened so you can squish
things I've flattened it I'm gonna call
it floor and on the ball I've said this
ball is made up of components it has a
position component which is called a
transform which is this thing over here
it has a mesh which is a sphere it has a
mesh renderer which is the thing that
makes the sphere appear in the real
world in the game and has a sphere
Collider and a rigidbody these things
make it affected by the physics engine
which unity ships with I've also applied
a thing called bouncing material to it
which I'll show you in a second but most
importantly I've ticked this box here
use gravity and that means it'll be
affected by gravity as you'd expect now
if I delete this one because that's a
bit of a spoiler and run this simulation
you'll see the ball falls to the ground
and not much else happens okay if I want
it to bounce I need to give it some
bounciness so I've made this bouncing
material which is a thing that says this
is bouncy not much not much to it and
it's got bounce combined and maximum
which means every time it bounces it'll
get more bouncy very exciting
okay so I'm gonna drag that onto my ball
and I'll show you what happens then you
can probably guess right very exciting
okay that's my talk not um this is not
machine learning this is an idea with
machine like this is just a cool
simulation of a ball bounces that ball
will eventually bounce off screen
because we told to multiply its bounce
every time it's very exciting
hopefully this really quick example
shows you how easy it is to assemble
something that would take a little bit
more than the 30 seconds I took to build
this to code so you can build it very
visually very quickly so unity lets you
build 3d complicated scenes very very
quickly and that is why it is
interesting for machine learning so I'm
gonna switch to a completely different
scene now we've made a little racetrack
which some of you may have seen before
you saw me speak at PyCon it might move
a little racetrack
it's pretty much what you'd expect it's
a really boring little racecourse for
the machine learning experts in this
room yes if we train a car to drive
around this track it will not drive
around other tracks very well it will
local maximum problems all that that's
not the point
points to how easy this is in this track
we have a car this car is actually some
sort of dozer it's not actually so it's
a self-driving dozer more than as a
self-driving car we're gonna make this
self drive around the track and I'm
going to show you how easy it is to do
that so the first thing I'll show you is
I have made this car this is basically a
game okay so I hit play now assuming I
set everything up correctly earlier
you'll see that this lets me drive
around the track okay this is me
steering I'm very bad at steering I
cannot drive in the real world
I can't drive on computers okay so when
you crash it just reset you to the
nearest point okay so hopefully you all
have seen no racing game before or
played a racing game as exciting as this
one you can see that you know we can
drive around this track it's very good
that's not very interesting from a
machine-learning point of view so we're
gonna use machine learning to make the
car drive itself the way we're gonna do
is we're gonna make sure the cars camera
is failing to some sort of machine
learning system so if you look at this
car if I expand it over here you'll see
that it has a camera mounted to the
front right here and it points forward
so you can kind of see the view frustum
of the camera there's this like cowan
thing coming forward and you can see a
little preview down here what the camera
can see so this camera is mounted to the
front of the car and if the car drives
around the track which I'll show you in
a second you'll see the camera the front
of the car is connected to it okay so
it's moving with the car we're gonna
feed that camera into a machine learning
system and teach the car to drive around
the track by itself the way we're gonna
do that is we're gonna use these white
points if you look on the track there's
these orange things here which are
spaced around the track relatively
evenly and if you like my scene to show
you those so you can see one there and
then if I go forward okay so they're
going on the track when the car leaves
the the track and goes through one of
these colliders on the outside we reset
to the nearest [ __ ] yellow thing okay
make sense to everyone it's pretty
straightforward
that that's code I'm not gonna show you
just trust me that works that's what
what's happening when I was crashing
earlier now I'm gonna turn on some
machine learning and show you how this
works but first I'm going to show you
the cars code and if you don't like
c-sharp it's time to avert your eyes I I
really like c-sharp it's actually grown
what got over the years it's one of my
favorite languages it's not suitable for
the same things python suited before but
it's a very good language in its own
right so I'm gonna open the cars code
and this is the code attached to the car
itself so there's a lot of junk here
because unity is a game engine and comes
with a lot of baggage because it's
basically we have we have a system that
simulates a car so if I look back in
unity for a second you'll see on our car
there's a whole bunch of parameters over
here that you know relate to cars
because if you want to build a car game
you need all these parameters when we're
not using most of them in fact the car
automatically steers forward drives
forward it accelerates and we have only
control we have is left and right
because we don't want to make a machine
learning but thanks to it too long to
train so if I go back to the code you'll
see we have all that all the junk to set
that up the most important thing here is
this agent action thing which is the
thing we implement to adhere to the
requirements of this ml agents toolkit
and this agent action says when this
action comes in we either go left or
right to get to get me minus one on one
and we tell the kind of move with that
action that's all that's doing okay and
then we check in with collided so if
we've hit something we've gone outside
the edge of the track we penalized the
car with a minus one floating point and
we reset the car to its nearest point
and if we did not hit something we give
the car a very tiny reward very small
reward very large penalty okay it's
really important that you tune these
numbers these numbers are more up than
they are science if anyone's done your
machine learning you'll know that this
kind of takes a while to get right this
is something that we came up with it
kind of works okay okay there's a
collect observations thing here which
allows us to pass information about the
scene into the machine learning system
we can give any sort of vector input we
want in here so if we wanted to measure
the distance from the walls we could
send invisible red lasers called ray
casts in the video game world out into
the walls and measure how far away those
are we're not going to do that here
we're actually going use visual
observations so we're just using that
camera on the front and that's I think
we can set up visually inside unity so
here we have an agent action the car can
steer left or right - 101 and even hit
something it gets penalized if it's
still driving it gets a small reward
okay that's literally it back in unity
you'll see we have our camera attached
to the car and we have this thing called
a car Academy which is the thing that
just mediates between the ability to
learn and the ability to control unity
and here we have a learning brain I'm
gonna click control on this learning
brain this means we're using an inter
process bridge to talk to Python that's
all that control textbox does and then I
show you the contents of that brain
you'll see that it has a visual
observation of 32 by 24 in grayscale and
that's that camera attached to the car
okay that's that literally it has a
space type space size of 1 1 1 1 action
which basically means that vector has
one thing inside it which is a minus 1
or a 1 that's literally it
ok that's the only setup we need to do
in unity so I'm actually I live there's
one more thing I need to do there's this
if I connect the learning brain to the
car I had a player brain there before
which allows me to drive the car with
keys so this is what a player brain
looks like a player brain just exists so
you can use the machine learning
subsystem to test your world and drive
it around the keyboard so I had exactly
the same setup here but it was mapped to
keys colleges for sniffing along so now
we've set the car to use the learning
brain we're going to go into a Python
script very exciting first thing I'm
going to show you there is some hyper
parameters all machine learning these
type of parameters very straightforward
lots of magic numbers don't worry about
it okay has anyone done machine learning
and familiar I'm talking about ok yep
high parameters lots of magic numbers
these have been tuned over the last few
weeks of us iterating on this project to
get it right
more interesting we're using a trainer
called PPO which is called proximal
policy optimization it's a very generic
but useful machine learning algorithm it
kind of does lots of things kind of well
it's not perfect for all situations
though and here we have a specific set
of parameters for our car that's really
it
ok so I'm gonna fire up this Python
script and I'm going to show you how
this can work with more interesting
Python I'm gonna run this Python command
ml agents learn which is just a nice
wrapper around PPO you're gonna point it
to our Yama file and I'm gonna give it
an ID ok so that's gonna fire up unities
ml agents and then ask us to push play
in the unity editor ok start training by
pressing play
so if I push play in unity this will
stop training
hence the flow will complain because
that's what tensor does and then
eventually it will start training with a
bit of luck
again this is very sorry ok so you can
see here shrink a little bit this is
training and slowly getting a reward
what this is doing is taking completely
random actions in that - 1 - 1 action
space and seeing how its rewarded or
penalized if I got a community it will
be lagging but it will be kind of
driving so you'll see it's moving the
car around when it gets penalized gets
penalized when it gets rewarded gets
rewarded and we can see that reward
happening here if you're familiar with
tensor board from more serious machine
learning projects you can use that as
well so if I go here and fire that up
you can see here this is all over the
place right now because it's really
early in its training run but it does
show you what's going on so you want the
reward to go up slowly over time
this is reinforcement learning so we're
pairing actions with observations and
rewards and trying to guide it towards
an optimal policy of driving now
realistically this will take you know 10
or so hours if we're leaving it to train
in my computer to get somewhere we
haven't got that much time so I'm going
to show you what I've prepared earlier
because that's what we do so I'm gonna
kill that you'll see here it right at an
end file which is just a neural net from
tensorflow that's a PP file I read here
one of those so I'm just gonna show you
how it works very exciting I'm gonna go
back into unity and I'm going to go on
to my brain which is our learning brain
here then you'll see here we've got a
slot for a model and I've got one I
prepared earlier which is this one to
infer on the GPU this is actually not a
problem not the kind of situation we'd
want to actually use a GPU for but I'm
gonna leave it alone and then I'm gonna
turn off that control thing because we
don't want places to control it you
needyou does not use Python for
inference it only uses Python for
training and I'll show you some more
pipe in a second for those of you prefer
python to see sharp things I'm gonna
click play now this brain was trained
for about a day and you'll see it's
driving itself it's as bad as I am
basically at this point but it is at
least driving itself which is a positive
thing that's very good that's very
interesting we can make a game that's
really fun no that's not the fun bit
okay
Python is the fun bit so that's great we
made it work but now I turn this control
thing back on and remove the brain
remove the model from the brain and go
into Jupiter so I have Jupiter running
here
everyone loves doop it up I'm gonna run
some code here you know zoom in so you
can see it you know say train mode true
I'm gonna run that I'm gonna run some
Python code so we're gonna import map
plot numpy pill the usual stuff and I'm
going to import some stuff from unity
okay so I'm gonna run that one as well
I'm gonna just check the Python throws
just correct machine learning mostly
often usually kind of requires Python
3.6 don't worry about it
well I'll talk about it later if you
have a question I'm not gonna ask unity
to give me a hand while its environment
you'll see this message we saw before
start training by pressing playing unity
so if I go back to unity and hit play
then come back here you'll see it gets a
hand on me the environment here and it
knows there's a learning brain with one
visual observation no vector
observations so there's no numbers being
fed into it only that one visual
observation and it has an action space
of one okay so it can take that -
one-on-one action there's also the
player brain which is the thing I was
using to steer it with the keyboard it
can see them both now we can grab a
handle on that and just make sure we've
got it so yeah we've got a handle on the
learning bone here I can now have a look
at that environment and print it out so
there's no vector observations but I can
see out that camera so that's my 32 by
24 grayscale camera coming out of unity
I can keep running out so I can get more
of it was moving you know it's very very
interesting but now I can take random
actions in their environment so here I
am using Python to basically say take a
random step using that continuous action
range so minus one to one in our
environment and do it 10 times then I
click play you'll see I can spit this
out in Jupiter here in this place that
means you have complete control of Lili
from within Python and you can make it
do your bidding you can ignore the
machine learning side you want and just
use this to control
and build a simulation I know lots of
people using unity to build environments
that are high enough fidelity
representations of the real world then
they're using unity cameras to capture
images of that and using it to train
machine learning for things that work in
the real world completely unrelated to
the simulation so if you need a really
high fidelity simulation and you want to
capture it with Python this is a really
good solution for that this is kind of
mind-blowing ly useful and when we
finish we close the environment which
disconnects it then releases unity back
to us so this is a really useful thing
if you need to do something with machine
learning so I'm not going to go into any
more depth about the plateau stuff
there's a really good Python API that
lets you go through everything this
thing so there's a full API here that
you can use to basically figure out
whatever you want to do and there's a
big Python API here which lets you grab
stuff from the Union environment so you
could ignore the machine learning side
and just use this to control unity which
is something I recommend you start with
the thing I want to show you next in my
last 10 minutes or so is how ridiculous
this can get so this is an environment
that we didn't build but I think is
really cool so if you've ever seen the
those ridiculous walking demos where the
thing is negative self walk you can
implement that yourself so this this
thing has taught itself to walk kind of
this is about 12 hours of training
because I didn't have time because I my
computer booked itself yesterday or the
day before so I had to retrain all these
this is about 12 hours of training this
thing I pull up the docks because I keep
forgetting this thing this thing has
this thing has 26 degrees of freedom on
a whole bunch of body parts hips chest
spine head thighs shins feet arms
forearms and hands its goal is to move
towards the goal direction and it gets
rewarded for velocity a velocity in the
goal Direction head position up so
staying upright
body direction alignment with goal so
it's not veering off its goal and it
gets penalized for head velocity
difference from body velocity so yeah
that's basically how humans walk if you
unpack it it's not definitely there's
not meant to be funny that is how humans
walk and it gets observation space from
the world it's it's in so it can see the
rotation velocity angular velocity and
the position of all of those 215
different variables if it's joints that
muscle it means it ends up doing this
because it's not it's not really walking
so much as its kind of flinging itself
in the direction of where it needs to be
however this has not been animated and
you can build anything you like using a
system like this so I'm just going to
unpack this a little bit more for you
because I think it's worth learning so I
still have ten minutes left
I think I'll show you one more thing
we've built a little warehouse okay so
this is a little warehouse with a little
robot in it this robot needs to push
this cube into the goal over here okay
so we've given this robot lasers he has
perfect lasers that can show where he
needs to be so his lasers are these
things have you see here he has one two
three four five six seven lasers going
out at different angles around his body
he can detect the crate he can detect
the goal he needs to get to and he knows
what's a wall and he sends those that
set of lasers out twice one at one level
and one in another level okay
he gets rewarded actually he gets
penalized for every single move he makes
which is designed to make him take
economy of movement so he's designed he
needs to take as minimal steps as
possible to achieve his goal and when he
delivers his package to the correct
place he gets five okay so this is him
this is him going and you can see the
lasers flashing I can turn those off
those are not right but you see the
little guy pushing it around he's pretty
good at his job
right but we can make him really
confused really quickly which kind of
demonstrates how and why machine
learning does what it does so we could
code this pretty quickly we were just
coding this
as a heuristic but this is learnt to
push this around so if I open a
different versions of warehouse where
there's multiple goals of different
colors and multiple crates but leave the
machine learning brain exactly the same
he's gonna freak out so if you don't
feel comfortable seeing here robot
freaked out now is the time to look away
this robot knows that he needs to push
crates into goals but he doesn't have
any concept of color so he just rapidly
gets very stressed
he'll occasionally do something correct
he doesn't know he doesn't know why he's
getting he's basically getting hit every
time something happens here if he gets
punished too much the environment resets
itself so you may see everything
disappear
basically if he files too much we kill
him um I'm gonna put him out of his
misery but before I put him at ease I'm
just gonna show you one quick really sad
thing there's actually hundreds of them
all going at once it's because when you
do machine learning you want to train in
parallel so the more information you can
feed into the brain the better so often
these environments are duplicated
repeatedly so this is just a really
quick taste of what you can do unity is
completely free if you're not using it
to build video games and making over
$100,000 it's not open-source the Python
bridge lets you pretty much control
anything you like within unity and comes
with a bunch of scripts that allow you
to train things that do all sorts of
stuff without having to think about it
much so if you are interested in
learning about machine learning this is
a very accessible way to getting into it
it uses tensorflow it uses all the
industry standard de facto standards for
this stuff so you're learning real
useful skills and you're doing it in a
really visual way okay you could even
visualize just a regular on your network
but put it in a visual form so you can
see what's going on so we teach a lot of
children how to do machine learning with
this and they instantly grasp it when
they can see it moving and it's really
open people's eyes like nothing else I'm
gonna show you one other thing I'm just
gonna give you a bit of a content
warning before I show you it looks like
a spider to some extent so if you do not
like spiders you might wanna look away
it's not very spider like it just has
lots of legs okay so that is your
warning here is our spider it's gonna
clear those areas okay so this is a
spider Bop that has taught itself to
walk we built this one it is its goal is
to follow that that orange cube around
the orange cube is just moving around
the environment randomly the spider
knows where it is but doesn't know much
else it can be hit by it now it gets
rewarded for facing it and approaching
it and getting close to it it gets
penalized for pretty much everything
else and it's totally self to walk so
this is pretty simple example
pretty straightforward but we thought
you know video game engine we need to
make this more something that gamer
would like so we gave the spider bot a
gun so here is AI spider bot and here's
a gun Milt which I've turned off and is
going to turn the gun mount on so the
gun is actually a completely separate a
AI agent that is sitting on top of the
spider so it's effectively a spider bot
with a parasitic gun on top they're both
controlled by two completely separate
machine learning brains that were
trained with Python the bot is designed
to seek the cube the gun is designed to
kill the cube and they work together so
your thing's got a gun now it's pretty
efficient so we did this we did a
version of this at PAX the Penny Arcade
Expo which is a consumer gaming show
where we were trying to explain how
machine learning works to video gamers
with a capital video game and they we
are we hooked this up to a controller so
they could also play the robot and
attempt to destroy the cube quicker than
the bots and in the 30 seconds we let
them play the bot killed the cube 60
times in the human killed twice so the
machine overlords will win eventually
but this is about this is about an
hour's worth of work in in Python
immunity to get this going excluding the
visual aspects the thing I want to show
you before I finish is that this
behavior is embedded in the object so if
I go here and I do placate the robot
without doing anything else and just
move it slightly so there's a couple of
robots duplicate it again duplicate it
again alright so there's a couple of
robots there and run this there's now
more than one robot in the environment
in theory there are so our camera is
designed to track the main robot substr
go into the scene here they have no
concept of each other existing but they
know each other exist in the physics
engine so if you have enough of them
they will eventually make a big pile of
robots where one will ascend to the top
they will they will use the others as a
platform with which to shoot the cube
and then I'll just stay in this big
during chattering spider bot pile
it's horrifying it's legitimately
horrifying so I'm gonna show you one
more one more thing quickly because I've
still got three minutes left so this is
another unity demo that we didn't make
this unity so I have lots of unities
open this is tennis so this is tennis
which is two hands which are robots
trained with Python that can play tennis
okay and the fun thing about this one is
you can do imitation learning or
behavioral cloning so you can hook one
hand up to a human and have the other
one learn how to play the tennis based
on the human instead of based on reward
signals so you can do behavioral cloning
online and a recording which is
real-time using this algorithm and then
you can feed all the information into
Python and tweak it to your heart's
content
so that's unity with machine learning
for Python I'm going to go back to my
slides in quickly finish I'm gonna jump
to here so the brain is the thing that
encapsulates logic you can swap a brain
out for being controlled by human or you
can route your blame to Python to be
controlled by either a neural net you've
trained or for training purposes it's
really powerful the agent is the thing
inside unity which is the thing you're
controlling with your brain it assigns
rewards it's linked to a brain it
performs actions okay so the agent in
this case was the robot the hands the
spider bought the car hopefully that
makes sense and these three objects
exist inside unity and then talk to
Python to let you do the training okay
what we saw was reinforcement learning
today but you can also do imitation
learning as I said which is the behavior
for anything where you teach it as a
human what to do really really powerful
stuff can come out of this so the
reinforcement learning we did today was
actions observations and rewards we had
some actions we wanted to do which we
rewarded based on you know how it went
and we've got certain observations to
generate those rewards or not actions
are just a number so you know you can
handle it however you like in your game
engine as you saw I was taking minus one
for one direction and one for the other
direction when we had the car there can
be whatever observations can be vectors
so you can you know distance to a thing
or a count or a number or B pictures
coming from you news cameras rewards are
just more numbers okay reinforcement
learning is just this cycle of learning
until you converge on
or fewer can actually do the thing you
wanted to do brain academy agent this is
how it looks tends to flow is
communicating down the bottom when you
build an environment you kind of want to
think about how you construct it this is
pretty straightforward stuff coming up
with the actions observations is the
really tricky bit that's the art not the
science I recommend using the Python
bridge to start with via the Unity ml
agents learn script which is the
pre-made things and then moving to using
Jupiter and doing it yourself but you'll
cope with the process here's what you
need you need unity you can get it from
here
it's really cool it's mostly free got a
simulation with the self-driving car you
play it like a game make it make sure it
works
you also need Python I like anaconda but
you can use whatever environment you
like and you need very specific versions
of tensorflow because machine learning
something and then you need ml agents
which you can get from Kipp that's
pretty much it I really really really
like this I think a game engine is a
really great way to learn machine
learning and I hope you try it out if
you're interested in doing this with a
completely open source game engine
there's a game engine called got ogod T
o gog OT which is open source completely
free and has a similar project in the
works which works with tensorflow as
well thank you very much
thanks powers